Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round table
of dim lighting we're going
to be talking about our first memories.
And in general the
nature of first memories.
Yes.
So yeah we'll take a trip
down, all the way to the
beginning of memory lane I guess
we'll call it.
Let me just say
that you listening, and maybe
us talking, it isn't unlikely
that your first memory didn't even happen.
So if you don't wanna be disappointed.
I know my first memory
happened, there's no doubt.
Well a lot of people think that.
It's just 'cause it's so real to me.
And I've, you know, I had
an interesting conversation
with my kids about this that led to
a practice
Realization?
Oh a practice.
A practice
that I think can be applied to any--
What?
Any parent, or mentor, or
if you have influence on a
certain type of person.
Oh that's sounds sinister.
I'll just leave it at that.
But, you know, we should
acknowledge and I wanna acknowledge
that the last four weeks
in our "Lost Years" series.
Now full disclosure we're
recording this just a few days
before my episode, which
is part four, comes out.
So as we're recording this we
don't really have the benefit
of experiencing the response
to my episode so I'm still
anxiously awaiting that.
Everybody hated it.
But I do, that's your prediction?
But I do think that, I mean
yours has been out, we've
been processing that, we've
been talking about it a lot.
Well, lots of people
A lot of you using
#earbiscuits when we're
talking about it.
I think
that we've gotten, I think
it's very safe to say
that we've gotten more
engagement and reaction
to this series, so far,
even without your episode,
your episode's only gonna help.
Just where there's a
conversation that's happening
and there's lots of questions,
thoughts that are being put
out there and we have every intention
to continue the conversation.
So I think that, you know, us
talking about our spiritual
background and where we're
at now and this is now a part
of "Ear Biscuits" in general
and so we're gonna return
to that conversation so
that it's not just this hey
we talked about it and we're
never talking about it again.
So we're gonna, we'll use
your questions and comments
kind of as a springboard
to get us back into
that conversation but that
won't be the end of it either
and we can't, I don't know when
exactly we're gonna do that.
It won't necessarily be next week but.
Yeah, I'll say it'll
be sooner versus later.
You know we do want to continue
that conversation while
so many of you are.
We just have to process my
episode and then, you know,
gather up everything that
you've said using #earbiscuits
which we've been doing
so there's still time
for you to submit questions
or your responses.
It's kind of a new
experience to have this level
of a conversation going
on around the show.
I mean the fact that I think
the first reason that we did it
was for ourselves and even
without my episode not being
out yet I can honestly say
that it crossed a big threshold
in me even just recording
it and I know it was very
meaningful to just, for
us to put this out there
for ourselves and just
to know that it resonates
with so many people and, or
it conflicts with some people
even and you know it creates that dialogue
and a conversation.
I just think we're honored to
have a community of listeners
that are, the vast majority
it's cordial, it's loving,
it's positive.
And I will say, yeah I
definitely, and I tweeted
that out as a result of
just the initial reaction
that I got to my story.
The vast majority of people
regardless of where they're at
spiritually, whether that's,
you know, more similar to
what we used to be or more
similar to what we are now,
everyone has been, mostly
everyone has been like really.
Civil in the least but--
Civil and respectful.
Even kind.
And kind, and understanding and I think
that that is again we didn't
talk about this to create
some sort of division.
I understand that any time
you talk about religion
or politics you are just
stepping right into it especially
just sort of the climate
of our country right now.
You're asking people
to fight and thankfully
that really hasn't happened.
It happened a little bit
but we just wanna say
that this is not about
creating an us versus them,
an in group and an out
group kind of thing.
We just wanna have a dialogue,
we're just trying to have
an honest dialogue and
thank you for being a part
of that but let's just
remember to keep it cordial,
keep it curious and--
Respectful.
Respectful and we'll keep
the conversation going.
I also thought it was cool that the number
of conversations that we're
having with like our friends
from college, you know,
we're now having an ongoing
conversation with them about
all of this because I mean
they shared so many of
those experiences with us
and like if you listen to our
conversation about digital
relationships or conducting
friendships over text
that was instrumental in us
reconnecting with those friends
and now it's a really
rewarding conversation
that we're having with
them over this topic.
And there's people coming out
of the woodwork who we haven't
heard from in years who are
saying that they're listening.
It turns out being on "The
Tonight Show" doesn't do it
it's just talking about your background.
That's what gets all the,
that's where you get all
the phone calls and texts.
And you know what there's
also a number of people who
I think they're introduction
to us has been this series.
So there's people--
Well that's just based
on simply looking at the numbers, I mean.
Yeah there's people who are
listening I guess right now
that weren't listening five episodes ago.
So welcome, welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
If your first introduction
to this podcast or us
was the series we just wanna say welcome.
Welcome to the heard of mythical beasts,
that's what we call ourselves.
Yeah, we invite you to stick
around and listen to this
podcast every week or if you
wanna watch it you can watch
it on YouTube the following, what is it?
Saturday, Sunday.
Let's talk a little bit
about what the podcast is.
I mean I think it's also
just a moment to kind
of recognize for all of
you who've been listening
for a long period of time I
think you've seen an evolution
in this show from, you know,
talking to, interviewing
YouTubers years ago to doing
just a bunch of miscellaneous
stuff to kind of settling into
this place where it's just
two guys who grew up together,
who now work together,
who are still best friends
just doing life together
and processing it and talking about it.
Sometimes it's personal and
I think that's how we got to
telling our stories is that
we had told you so many things
about our past and our experience
and the way that we see
things and we had never
gotten into that specific
sort of giant part of who
we were so it just sort
of, it was just a lot of
critical mass building towards
this hey let's just
let you guys in on this
part of ourselves.
But it's really because
the nature of the show
that's what it's become,
it's become a very personal
sort of processing podcast.
Yeah I mean it's a big
part of us conducting
our friendship, you know,
and also like just reporting
and processing everything
that's going on in our lives.
So is this podcast just
gonna be about our spiritual
perspectives moving forward?
No, but it is, I think now
that we've, you know, unearthed
it that it'll much more readily be a part
of the conversation on any
given week which I, we were
starting to feel that tension
that there were certain things
that we could speak
about but that we weren't
quite there yet.
So I do think it, the "Lost
Years" series, impacts
the overall complexion and the,
I don't wanna say the tone,
but like the subject matters
of what we're gonna talk about.
But hey, basically, we're just
here to hang out with each
other and to hang out
with you so keep doing it
and keep coming back, we'll still be here.
It sounds like the end of the podcast.
Is that it?
All right, see you next week.
Nope, nope, nope, no, no, no, no, no.
We haven't even done anything yet.
And so sometimes we talk
about things that are just
interesting to us but we
usually try to find a personal
connection and that's why
we're talking about the nature
of your earliest memories.
Oh, we should also say if
you really don't have a point
of reference for this--
Okay, yeah, keep
plugging things, please.
We have five videos
a week on a show called
"Good Mythical Morning."
Yep there's that.
And every day
there's a "Good Mythical MORE" episode,
you can watch that too.
Every Saturday we do a vlog
where it's sometimes it's like
a video version of "Ear
Biscuits" in terms of a lot
of the stories that we'll tell.
I think a lot of those we're
capturing for our Saturday
release on our Rhett and Link
channel so check that out
if you haven't checked out our vlogs.
Youtube.com/rhettandlink.
Is that enough of the plugs
or should we just go full in
with like ads.
We should just go straight to an ad.
You can get.
Full plug, full plug right here.
Okay.
Look at that.
Full plug?
Plug, plug into this t-shirt.
You can get Link's t-shirt,
not the jacket but the t-shirt
at mythical.com and
it's not the only thing
that you can get there,
there's lots of other things.
Other t-shirts, long-sleeved
shirts, hoodies, pens,
there are notebooks, beard
oil, lip balm, pomade.
The list goes on.
I mean it's kind of, a mug.
Well the list isn't gonna
go on but it could.
Go to mythical.com rep your boys, bam.
Okay, so I know we're gonna
share like, we have done
this at some point.
We talked about everything
I think we've
mentioned things.
But I don't know.
We've probably mentioned what
our first memories are but.
I don't remember what yours is.
I've already forgotten your
first memory so that'll be fun.
You should remember your
friend's first memories.
I think that they don't
mean as much to someone else
if they were to remember
them as if you, as you
remembering them yourself.
And I don't, maybe we'll
unpack that there's, when we go
through the specifics of our
memories, that there is more
meaning in it than we even realized.
And it's funny because the
other night I was tucking Lando
into bed, he's nine years
old, and that's when we get
some good quality time.
He has this like hammock
seat, hammock chair thing
hanging beside his bed.
Sometimes I'll sit in that
and just dangle and we'll just
have a little conversation.
That's an odd word to use to put there.
And I don't know what
prompted this conversation
but I was like, Lando, what's
the first thing you remember?
I was just curious at his age
and we'd gotten into talking
about that and we landed in
a place where I felt like
I got a big idea.
You landoed in a place?
I landoed on a big idea.
So we can get back to what
his memory is our whatever
but where do you wanna start?
Oh that's, well you sounded
like you we're gonna
tell a story.
No I'm just saying
that's kinda why I wanted
to talk about this.
You're not gonna disclose
his first memory?
Oh I can, well he's, like
I said, he's nine years old
and when we moved to Los
Angeles he was one, you know,
so I was like how long did we
stay in that first apartment?
We only stayed there six
months, there's no way
he remembers that.
I'm like, and I was like
Lando you don't remember
living in an apartment
in Los Angeles right?
He was like, "No."
I was like yeah you were
in a crib there's no way
you could remember that.
And like, I was like then
we had this house after
that where we moved and we
stayed there for three years
and I started to describe the place.
I was like there was,
the driveway was blue
do you remember that?
And he was like, "No."
I was like there was a
hammock in the backyard.
Remember that hammock that
we got from like Kotulas
was a sponsor and it
was like this weird like
self-supporting hammock?
He definitely remembers this place.
It was green and I was
like do you remember that?
And he was like, "No."
And I like called Lincoln
in there like am I crazy,
do you remember this?
I was like you remember
all this, you remember it.
You mean in Encino?
Yeah in Encino when I lived there.
And then I started describing
the inside of the house
and he was like, "Hold
on I remember my bunk bed
"'cause did we have bunk beds?"
I was like yes.
And he was like, "And I was on
the bottom 'cause I remember
"I would have to reach up
and grab and hang stuff from
"the slats but I had to
force my hand in there
"because Lincoln was
laying on the mattress."
And I was like there
you go, do you remember
our purple couches?
He was like, "No."
He's not gonna remember that.
Not gonna remember that.
I was like and then Lincoln
came in there and he was like,
"Do you remember that
neighbor who you'd go over
"to his house and play and
he had a dog who was deaf?"
And Lando was like, "Yeah, I
would call him all the time
"and he would never respond."
'Cause he was deaf.
I was like yeah, he couldn't hear.
And then I was like he had
a rabbit and when they would
go out of town.
He was like, "Yeah, we'd
go over there and we'd feed
"the rabbit and they had a trampoline."
And that is what we determined
is his first memory.
A rabbit on a trampoline?
A deaf dog, a rabbit and a trampoline.
Wow.
Three totally separate things.
It sounds like an adult swim show.
Yeah.
If you can find those
three things you're in
for a good time.
Well it's interesting that
the way that you got him
to remember that because
that's kinda, that's one
of the articles that I'd
read from psychcentral.com
entitled "What's Your Earliest
Memory" from August 2018
by Janice Wood.
Good old Janice.
Got a great last name.
So there were these guys
at Emory University.
Would you like to remember
your first memory?
Researchers at Emory University.
So I'm just gonna quote
some of this: few adults can
remember anything that
happened to them before
the age of three.
Now a new study has documented
that it's about age seven
when our earliest memories
begin to fade a phenomenon
known as childhood amnesia.
So, you don't, now.
So everything up until,
everything from four years old
to seven years old you
remember and then after seven
you start to lose stuff.
I would say three to seven
because in this other article
and this is very pertinent
because so many people think
that they remember things.
Interestingly my first
memory comes from age three.
That's early.
Which is they say that's
about the earliest
that you can do it.
Let me see, what does it
say, okay, "About four out
"of every 10 people have
fabricated their first memory,"
according to researchers,
this is another article
at BBC, the bbc.com called
"Can You Trust Your Earliest
Childhood Memories?"
But basically, okay: they
examined the first memories
of 6,641 people and the
scientists found that 2,487
of the memories shared
such as sitting in a prom,
I don't know, I'm not
familiar with English terms.
Sitting in a prom?
Yeah, but P-R-A-M.
Oh a pram?
A pram, is that like some kind of like.
I don't know what that.
Some vehicle or something?
A pram is I think it's like a large
like little carriage to put a child in.
Oh okay, like a carriage?
Oh you put them on a
bassinet or like a stroller.
Yeah okay, yeah.
I think stroller.
So 2,487 memories, which
is almost half, were from
before the participants
had reached the age of two
with 14% of participants
claiming to remember an event
before their first birthday
and some even before
their own birth.
Oh gosh,
people don't go--
But the fact is.
People trying to be overachievers.
It's like you saying your
first memory is when you were
three because you know that
scientifically the earliest
you can so you're trying to achieve.
These people don't know the
science and they're lying too.
It basically just says that
your brain in not capable,
it doesn't have the structures
that it needs to form
the kinds of things
that you would carry on
and you may be like, "Well I was special
"and I remember being."
There are people who think
they remember being in their
mother's womb or they think
they remember their own birth.
And then a lot of people think,
in fact Freud taught this,
that you do have all those old memories
but you suppress them.
Listen, Freud, all he
did was grasp at straws
and make stuff up man.
But there's a good--
And, by the way, I know
nothing about him except
he makes stuff up.
Okay, here you go.
So young children tend to forget events
more readily .
Now I will say newborns do have memories
of being in the womb.
They will respond to
things on the outside based
on what they heard on the inside.
Like somehow science does things--
No, no I'm not saying, but
you don't have the ability
to retain those memories.
Retain those memories.
And bring them into adulthood.
She says, this one researcher says,
"Memories are like orzo,"
which is a pasta: referring to
the rice grain size pasta,
little bits and pieces
of neural encoding.
Young children's brains are
like colanders with large holes
trying to retain these
little pieces of memory.
As the water rushes out so do
many of the grains of orzo.
Adults however use a fine
net instead of a colander
for a screen.
Then you get to be our age
and that net gets a bunch
of holes in it.
So basically, I would say
but the childhood amnesia
thing is just the idea that
you've got these memories
that you remember from about
age three and then once you
turn seven, on average, you
begin to lose those memories
unless you've got some
mechanisms to continue
to remember them.
Right?
Yeah.
And a lot of times that can
be a picture or a video.
Yeah I think a lot of people
are just, their first,
they're remembering something
they projected on a picture
that they've looked at in a
photo album for years afterward.
Well yeah 'cause a lot of
time you're constructing
that memory.
And if you
got a photo from inside of a womb.
I've got lots of those.
You are a freak.
I've got a whole folder.
It's just called.
I don't wanna know
what it's called.
A sonograph.
I don't, oh.
Right, is that what it's called?
When you get, not sonograph.
What do you get when you go to?
Sonogram.
Sonogram?
Yeah, that's not what
I'm talking about.
I'm trying to remember all,
I try to forget.
I'm talking about as if
a baby took a Polaroid from the inside.
That's what they're doing now.
You pass in a Polaroid?
It's not.
And then the baby takes a picture?
Yeah, exactly.
Well that's not what happens
and I don't even know
how we got on this.
It's not very pertinent because it's--
People use, people will
see a picture from a point
in their past and then they will construct
a memory around it.
That's what happens a lot of times.
There's all kinds of ways
to implant false memories
but I don't wanna go too much
more into it 'cause I wanna
talk about what our memories
are but essentially if you
think you remember
something before the age
of three you probably don't.
If you think you remember it
before the age of two like when
you were like one or younger
you definitely don't remember
it and you need to come
up with a new memory.
And you know what?
We still accept you.
You know what you don't have
to, you don't have to remember
stuff from way back
then for us to love you.
I love you.
I love you if you don't remember
anything, you know, dang.
What's your first memory?
I was three.
It was Halloween which means
I had just turned three
which is pretty unusual
but, you know, I'm one
of those guys.
Maybe you had just turned four?
No 'cause it was in Georgia.
Okay.
After talking to my mom
maybe I had turned but it was
in Georgia and I think I
turned four in California
when we moved to Thousand Oaks.
Maybe I'd just turned four but
I think I'd just turned three
but this is my earliest memory.
Halloween, I had decided
to be Big Bird for reasons
that should be obvious.
I'm big, I like birds.
Do you remember being
hypersensitive to being the tallest
kid at that age?
Of course that might have
been your first memory so.
I don't.
I think kindergarten.
No, I've never had a sense
of being, like a real sense
of being that much bigger
and taller than people
until people keep telling
me that I am, right.
So I don't think I was very
self-conscious about it.
Even though you look at the
pictures and you're like how
did they, why did they
let this eighth grader
into this preschool class?
You know, is he a teachers
assistant 'cause he looks
a little young for that.
I guess choosing Big Bird
does reflect like a certain
either a confidence or
at least an ambivalence
to your height.
But I mean Big Bird's tall so
if you're choosing Big Bird
it's like I know I'm tall
and that's, this will work.
Well let's be clear here if
I was three years old I did
not select Big Bird, Big
Bird was selected for me.
Oh this is your parents shaming you.
Which this is, might need to
be something that I explore
in therapy is that--
That's right.
My mom most likely, my dad's
not picking out Halloween
costumes I know how he
is, my mom decided for me
that I should be Big Bird.
Now I remember being
very excited about being
Big Bird so maybe--
Was that your first memory, being excited?
No, I'm gonna tell you the first memory.
I'm gonna, this only, the
story only makes sense in light
of me actually being excited
about being Big Bird.
Okay.
Because I wanted to go trick
or treating, I was excited
to go trick or treating,
I was gonna get to go
with my brother who was
three years older than me.
Was he Wile E Coyote?
I don't even remember what
he was because this isn't his
memory it's mine.
You didn't even care, huh?
I feel like he might have been a robot
but I honestly don't remember.
I was Wile E Coyote one
year and I'm not even lying
and it might have been the same time.
I'll have to, I know there's a picture
of me as Wile E Coyote and
I've never realized this
until this moment.
But Wile E Coyote is like a
Warner Brothers character.
Oh shoot, I'm getting Big Bird.
Are you confusing the Sesame
Street universe with the--
I'm getting
Big Bird confused.
Looney Tunes?
With the Roadrunner.
Hey man, that would have
been a good coincidence.
Hold on, you were the roadrunner?
I was Wile E Coyote.
Oh, so that okay and
if I was the Roadrunner
that would have made.
If you, right.
But I was Big Bird.
I screwed it up man.
I thought that would
have been serendipity.
Back to your story.
And of course this was
1980 probably which meant
that my costume consisted
of like some sort of vinyl.
You know what I mean?
Plastic.
It was very plastic and if you recall.
It was like a plastic tarp
with a hole that your head
goes through and then a mask.
If you recall your memory
of Big Bird you might not
remember his legs.
Remember the color of his legs?
Orange legs with pink rings?
Yeah, I would've just said it was orange
and pink striped legs.
Like horizontal stripes
that go up the leg,
pink and orange, yeah.
And that's what I remember.
I'm not gonna bring up
a picture of Big Bird
because I want this to be a
pristine thing in my mind.
Okay.
And literally the first
step out the door I tripped
on something, fell down and
fell on my knee and ripped
a hole in the vinyl and also
kinda skinned my knee up.
And at that point it
was that I'm embarrassed
because my hole, my
costume has a hole in it.
Yeah I think you knew if
people looked at your knee
they would know there's
a human under there.
They're like that's not Big Bird I can see
a human knee under there.
Yeah.
And so the whole plan had fallen apart
and I just stayed in, what I
remember, again, I don't know
what part is constructed and
what part actually happened.
I remember staying inside
and they had to like bring,
you know, like my brother would
bring me some of his candy
like I had to use some of
his candy 'cause I didn't
actually go outside.
So you just stayed, you stayed
back with your dad probably
and your mom took your brother out.
Don't remember those details.
I just told you everything
that I remember.
Okay, so that's your first memory.
There's a little trauma there.
Maybe a lot of trauma.
It seems like a lot.
I'd be interested in what
your parents say about this.
What I keep, when I was
walking across the parking lot
this morning you were sitting
in your car on the phone.
I thought I heard your mom's voice.
You did.
You were talking to your mom in the car?
You should have asked her about this.
Erm, I didn't, she's not gonna remember.
You talking about something else?
What else is there to talk about?
My dad called me last
night, this is a side note,
I mailed him finally, I mailed him
"Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
finally and I also gave him
one of our records.
You know Mythical Society
when we covered Merle
and it comes, you know it
comes with that sticker in it
that says Mythical Recording?
And my dad was talking about
the record and he said he liked
the album cover and all that
stuff and how if you turn
it over it's the reverse.
And then he said, "And now,
you know that little thing
"that says 'Mythical Recording' on it?
"If I were to peel that off
would that stick on something
"or would that mess it up?"
And I was like, "Yeah it's
fine dad it's a sticker.
"It is a sticker.
"I think that's the word
you're looking for."
He was like, "Well okay,
I knew what a sticker was
"I just didn't know if
this was a sticker."
It sounds like you had
a much more interesting
conversation than I did with my mom.
We didn't talk about stickers at all.
Well, so do you wanna hear my first memory
and then we'll analyze both of 'em?
Okay.
My first memory was, let's see,
before I went to preschool.
So I went to preschool when I was like six
and then, or five?
No I went to kindergarten
when I was six, preschool
when I was like five, so from
the age of like two to four
I stayed at Retta's house.
Loretta, you met her, she
was my first babysitter.
She only kept me and my
first best friend Brad
that I talk about in
the book of Mythicality
and so my first memories are
at her house where I would
spend the day.
I remember one day we would
always stay at her house
we would rarely leave and maybe
that's why I remember this
because it was very unusual
because we did leave.
We went to a friend of hers
house and it was maybe a mile
or two away still a way in the
country and there was this,
we were playing in the
backyard and there were some
other kids there.
I remember being very
afraid of other kids.
Like even in preschool.
I don't know, I liked the
people that I knew man and--
But what were you afraid of?
I don't know.
What was gonna happen?
Just the peopleness of 'em.
I don't know, I haven't gotten into that.
But I do remember I was in
the backyard and I was on the
swing set thing and you know
they got like normal swings
and they're like metal swings
but you've got this certain
type of swing that it's got two
benches that face each other
and then so as it swings
it kinda stays parallel.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like a very old-timey type swing.
But it's two people facing
each other on this thing.
You never been on one of those?
And you stay--
You were probably too tall.
You stay at the same height?
You stay parallel to the
ground but you move up and down
'cause it's kinda like
a rowboat kinda vibe.
I don know it's kinda, there's two.
I think you're making this up.
There's two.
I think even the swing
is a fabrication.
There's two bars.
There's two bars that come down.
One in front of one person and
one beside the other person.
Oh, it's not on a chain?
No it's on bars and they're
fixed and you're facing
the other person.
Okay.
I was on it by myself and
I was holding onto the bars
and I remember--
Facing no one.
It like, I'm pretty sure it
pinched or the way I would
have said it at the
time was, it pinched me.
It pinched my hand and
cut it and there was blood
and my recollection is
there was a lot of blood
and I remember running
into this stranger's house
and trying to find Retta and--
Well first of all before
you continue I will say
that they don't make jungle gym
equipment like they used to.
Oh no.
I actually believe,
everything is so safe now,
I think that there should be
a way that a kid could come
away from a piece of equipment bleeding
just as a life lesson.
Maybe with one less ear.
Yeah, I mean I think that
every piece of playground
equipment that is manufactured
now should have like
one really unnecessarily sharp point.
Yeah, like a jagged edge.
So that at least once a year
one kid really gets snagged
on that thing.
And then the custodian should
come out with a paint brush
of tetanus and just
kinda like brush it on.
Well tetanus is probably over
kill but I think you gotta
have some blood and some scars.
What else are you gonna remember?
As we're demonstrating here.
So I run into Retta and I love this woman.
She's very short.
I think I bond with people
who are of extreme heights.
My wife's pretty tall for her height.
For her height?
For her age, I don't know
what I was gonna say.
Your pretty tall for your height baby.
For her sex.
Okay, you could say
pretty tall for a woman.
Okay, yeah, yeah, she's a woman.
That's beside the point.
Loretta was very short.
Sometimes the way out--
She's like four, 10.
Is a lot easier than you make it.
Loretta was like four, 10.
She was like the most
approachable person to a kid
and she made me feel better.
That's my first memory.
Did she kiss it?
I don't think.
Did she kiss your boo-boo?
She cleaned it up, she
cleaned up the boo-boo.
And I don't remember Brad
being there but I remember,
my second memory, and again
it may have come first
I really have no way to know,
was the one I tell in the book
of Mythicality and that's I
go into the bathroom right
after he came out of the
bathroom and he forgot to flush
and there was a turd in
there that was bright orange
and I will never forget
that Cheeto colored turd.
It shocked me.
You gotta have something
sensational like an orange turd
is definitely something that's
not gonna leave your brain.
It was like a guy directing
traffic around a construction
site on the street, you know.
You gotta wear the most
like fluorescent orange
vest type situation.
What if it--
It was like he crapped
a construction vest.
But what if it wasn't a turd?
Have you ever thought about that?
It was a turd man.
Are you sure that it wasn't
just like a giant Cheeto
or like a cheese puff of some kind?
That he was like I don't
wanna eat this and he threw it
in the toilet and it
expanded to turd size.
You talking about a Cheeto
the size of a baby's arm.
That's how big it was?
Yeah man, I'll never forget it.
So one of those two are my first memory
and they're equally traumatic
and I think that's the common
denominator here between our two stories.
Right, and I don't have any
other memories from Georgia
which is where I spent
my first three years.
It's funny because I would
have told you that I remembered
when it snowed that winter
when I was three years old
but I don't actually remember
it I've just seen the pictures
because I do.
I've seen the pictures of my
mom, I've seen the pictures
of me and my brother with
plastic bags tied over our feet.
It's funny like we were in south Georgia--
You were very ill prepared.
We're in south Georgia and my mom's idea
of like keeping us safe in
the snow is to put slippery
plastic bags around our feet
and send us out into the snow.
You don't want your feet to get wet.
Right, you just want to
fall and break something.
I think when you're a parent
especially, I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna project this
on your mom and assume
that she wasn't actually thinking
this, but especially back
then, you know, you'd put
your kids out the front door
and you'd say, "Don't come
back for a couple of hours."
Matter of fact there's a couple
of times that I've even said
that to my kids now.
I'm like, you know what?
I'm fed up with these screens.
Go outside and do not come back
in for and I'll say an hour.
An hour's a long time.
But like 15 minutes later
they ring the doorbell.
Well if you send 'em out in
the snow and you don't put
bags over their socks and
shoes then once those socks
get wet, "I gotta come inside mom.
"It's Rhett, it's your Big Bird boy."
First of all I was three
I'm pretty sure she didn't
I gotta go back inside.
leave me and it was snowing
in Georgia which was very
unusual and I think that's why
I thought that I remember it
but I think it's just a picture.
You think your mom put plastic
bags around her own shoes?
No.
It's like Reeboks that are back
in style now.
I don't think so.
The additional things that I
remember is that there's just
sporadic things from my time
in Thousand Oaks, California.
What's your first memory from there?
So this will be your second memory.
I honestly can not put these
in chronological order.
I don't know.
Because I remember being
taught how to ride a bike
and falling and falling a few
houses down and then my pants
getting caught in the chain
and not being able to move
and having to yell for
my dad to come after me.
And that's probably, I
probably combined two memories
because there was when I
was learning to ride my bike
and then me riding my
bike probably by myself
and that happening.
I remember a giant sunflower.
What?
Yeah this is the only
good memory that I have
from back, from really early.
You know what if you really
look at a giant sunflower
from up close I would
argue that it's actually
pretty damn scary.
They're kinda wicked.
When was the last time you
stared down a sunflower?
It's like the black part
in the center is just,
is a lot bigger than you
feel like it should be
and it looks, and the stuff
that's coming out of it,
the seed stuff, to me it's
like, it's gross looking.
But how do you remember it?
Well I think of it differently
now that you said that.
To me it's like staring at a
beautiful sun that you can't
not, that you can look
at without looking away.
I guarantee it was twice
as big as your head if it
was a good one.
In my recollection it was
eight to nine feet tall.
Right.
It was pretty tall for its height.
But you weren't afraid of it?
See that's the thing for me as
a kid I would have definitely
been afraid of that flower.
And I also remember the first
time I heard the F word.
Oh really?
From Rochelle.
Who's Rochelle?
Rochelle was the coolest
kid in our neighborhood.
She was probably like five to
six years older than I was.
Okay.
And I heard her say it and
then I went up and whispered
in her ear and I said, I just
wanted to make sure I had
gotten it right and I was
like, "Is a bad word?"
And she was like, "What did you say?"
And I said.
And what did she say?
She said, she started laughing and said,
"Yes it's a bad word, you can't say that."
Even though I just said
it, I whispered it twice
into her ear.
So she just said it in conversation?
Yeah, yeah and then this is
like 1981 and you got this
girl just saying the F word
in front of four year olds.
I don't remember the first
time I heard the F word.
I remember the, when the
Beastie Boys cassette
"Licensed to Ill" came out with like
"Fight for Your Right to
Party" on it and by this point
my babysitter's name--
Why do you only remember
things in the context
of being babysat?
Because I was babysat a lot.
My mom was working.
My mom was working man.
I know that but like you
also, you did have a home
and a mom and like.
I think, yeah and we do, I
have memories, I'm saying
but my mom didn't use the F word homie.
You would have remembered it if she did.
My mom didn't say, "Hey, let
me open up the liner notes
"to this Beastie Boys album
and let's, I'm gonna highlight
"every single naughty
word so you can learn it."
That's what Joe, the older boy, did.
He would literally point
to every single nasty word
and he would also tell me
about the female anatomy.
Well you need to know about that.
Like in detail.
You know there's like certain
things you can say in general
about down there and then you can also go
like really anatomical.
Right.
Like imagine the most
anatomical conversation
and I guess I was, I don't know, you know,
I might have been 10.
Oh so you passed .
But I mean.
You've passed forward all the way to 10.
Well I mean if we're talking about like--
Which is pretty sporadic.
What's my first memory of
being taught something illicit
is now what we're talking about.
Oh, okay.
My first illicit memory is then.
And you know what?
A few days later Joe's
younger brother got sick
and he was laying on the
floor, the same floor
that we laid on when we
were like trying to hide
the Beastie Boys liner notes
and he started to vomit.
And the kid started to vomit
and instead of rolling over
on his side or standing up
or running to the bathroom
he rolled over on his
back and he was projectile
vomiting straight up in the
air and you can die from
that, you can easily choke.
Burgh, like a fountain,
like a vomit fountain?
Yeah and so I think somebody
came and pushed him over.
Like did a log roll.
It's like you just can't,
you just can't let a kid.
Do that sideways man.
If we're talking about, I
told you this story about
my babysitter trying to
dare me to pull the wart
off her finger.
Oh gosh, you have so many--
Like she was
I mean.
Screwed up man.
God rest her dead soul but
we would sit in the swing
and wait for my mom to come
to show up and I would always
be the last one to get picked
up because my mom worked late
she was a hard working
woman and I was so anxious.
I had this separation
anxiety and so I was afraid
that my mom wasn't going to pick me up.
So while you're waiting
you can try to get a wart
off an old woman's hand.
We would sit in the swing
and she would, she'd look up
and she'd say, she'd look down
the street, it was a long,
long driveway, she'd
look down the driveway
and she'd say "There she don't come."
That was here joke,
"there she don't come."
And I was like, I could
tell by the look on her face
it was like oh my mom's coming.
And then after screwing with me--
You can't just stop for a second.
Well I'm just gonna pile it all on
and then you can unpile it.
So then in that same scene
she would say, in order to
occupy my time while I
was waiting for my mom
and she was taunting me, she would say,
"See if you can pull off
this wart from my finger."
And I would, it was a
big wart it was like--
This woman was like a witch.
It was the size of an infant's pinky.
She was a witch Link.
And it was on the side of
her index finger like between
the second and final knuckle
there was a wart on the side
and I would grab this wart and pull.
And I actually, I would
sometimes I would dig my
fingernails underneath it
and that would make me happy
'cause I knew that I was
hurting her a little bit
but she would just grit her
teeth and she would not,
she wouldn't, it was
like a game of mercy--
I think she thought
you might actually pull
it off one day.
She either
She was like,
"This boy's gonna get
wanted that thing off
this wart off."
Or she didn't want to admit
that I was yanking her hard on that wart.
Okay, let's talk about this.
I remember all that y'all.
These are my memories.
Link.
Anatomically detailed.
This woman was a witch.
Do you remember what she looked like?
No.
She picked me up one day,
she had, why are we talking
about this woman?
She had a long Cadillac but
it was two doors but the doors
were as long as what
would normally cross like
a stretch limo's worth of three doors.
It was the longest door.
A kid couldn't open the door.
A teacher had to come as she
pulled up, opened the door
for me and let me get in the
back seat and then she had
the window rolled down I
remember I'm putting my hand
out the window one day and
I was sitting behind her
as she was driving and she's leaving
Boyds Creek Elementary School
and she starts rolling up
the window and I tried to take
my hand out but the window
rolled up so quickly that my
hand got stuck and I was like,
"Oh my hand's in the
window, my hand's stuck."
And she rolled it down a
little bit and as I was about
to pull it out she rolled it up again.
She kept my hand in the window
dude just to screw with me.
She was demented.
Hold up but why do you have,
you don't have fond memories
of her you have horrific memories of her.
I don't understand why
that hasn't registered.
This is not Retta.
I loved Retta, I still love
Retta, she's still alive
and she's a beautiful
four foot 10 inch woman.
And I'm not exaggerating,
that's how tall she is.
With no warts on her hand.
No warts, beautiful small hands.
Big hair though.
Because when I think--
She had the hair
of a giant.
When I think about those days.
Again my first memory was
traumatic but like when
I think about--
I bottled all that shit up
too man, I never once told
my mom about any of that.
Yeah, that's a problem.
Yeah.
Like four, five, six I
remember there was a guy in our
neighborhood who had a
pitbull who would pull him
at very high speeds while he was on
a skateboard bare footed.
What, that's Cali.
That's Cali for you.
Yeah but that's the
kind of, I mean I've got
good memories--
Did he have a wart?
You have good memories?
I remember
the Santa Ana Winds would come
and my brother and I would
put on giant jackets and
go and hold them open
and lean completely into the
wind so it would hold us up.
Like I'm not saying I
didn't have bad memories
but there were no women with
warts that were trying to get
me to pull them off and there
was no evil woman trying
to get my hand stuck in the
window or getting my hand stuck
in the swing.
I mean do you remember anything good?
Nobody made me get my hand
caught in the swing, okay.
Do you have any good memories?
But the other two things that
happened were both the same
woman so at least they
were of the same woman.
I mean if those are two
different women, that would suck.
I did have another babysitter
who would say, "Go outside."
She'd make me go outside for
the hour that she was watching
"The Bold and the Beautiful"
or whatever soap opera
she was into and I hated it
because it was just like I would
sit on the steps waiting for
her show to be over so I could
go back inside.
That's not babysitting.
Yeah it's horrible.
And you didn't think, "I
think I need to tell my mom."
I don't, I think I did
complain about that woman
and then I stopped going there.
Oh good for you.
Stopped going there.
How did we get on this?
So, I mean clearly the trauma.
I have good memories too.
I have good memories from my childhood.
Name one.
I remember the wart didn't come off.
Yeah I don't, I could probably
come up with some good
memories but what's the fun in that?
Well, okay, kind of getting
back to what you talked
about with Lando.
Yes.
In this same article from
psychcentral this is pretty
interesting, so okay: research
is showing that infants
do not have the sophisticated
neural architecture needed
to form and hold on to more
complex forms of memory.
Okay: for their experiment
the researchers recorded 83
children at the age of three
while their mothers or fathers
asked them about events
that they had experienced
in recent months such as a trip to the zoo
or a birthday party.
Bower explained that parents
were asked to speak as they
normally would to their
children prompting them
with questions such as,
"Remember when we went to
"Chuck E. Cheese's for
your birthday party?
"You had pizza didn't you?"
The child might then recount
details of the birthday party
or divert the conversation to
another event such as a visit
to the zoo.
The researchers noted that
some mothers might keep asking
about pizza while other mothers
would ask about the trip
to the zoo.
Parents who followed a child's
lead in these conversations
tended to elicit richer memories
from their three year olds
according to Bower.
This approach also related to
the children having a better
memory of the even at a later age.
Okay and then in this study,
'cause I read about this too,
years later they went back
and asked them about those
same memories to see what
was retained and what wasn't.
Yeah, 'cause it says: while
the children between the ages
of five and seven could
recall 63 to 72% of the events
the children who were eight
and nine years old remembered
only about 35% of the events
the researchers reported.
So if you've got kids.
Yes, this is what I'm getting at.
Now first of all I'm just
gonna go ahead and tell you--
There's an opportunity here.
For the youngest child
between the two of us is nine.
Right.
So you've already missed the
window, you should have been
doing this at five and seven
and so only if you've got kids
who are younger than
seven years old listen up
because I think we've
got a technique for you.
Yeah, this is exactly what
occurred to me when I just
happened to be talking
to Lando about this.
I was like, "Dude," and I
didn't know about the seven
and nine but I was like:
Okay you're nine years old,
you're so much closer to all
of these memories than I am
to my memories or even that
older kids are to theirs
I can help you remember more details.
We can sit here, we can
talk about the details
of that house in Encino,
riding the scooter all the way
around it, getting in that hammock.
He started to remember stuff
about the rabbit and like all
the stuff in that kid's house
when we'd go feed the rabbit.
I was like, "You know what,
now that's your first memory."
It doesn't involve a wart,
it doesn't involve bleeding
and this is a gift that parents,
or mentors, or cool uncles
or aunts can give--
Short babysitters.
To your, short babysitters,
you can give to your progeny here.
You can help them, you can
establish richer first memories.
I mean it's, you know, there's
the gift of like our parents
gave us the gift of all the
pictures that we have, you know.
Those, the plastic wrapped
around your legs, your feet.
You don't really remember
that but you almost could have
and if you would have
talked about it at age seven
and then kept talking about it.
We've talked about how the
act of remembering creates
the memory again and
makes it more memorable.
Well it re-writes it as well.
Re-writes it, so, hey this
is another weighty thing
that you might interpret as
pressure, that's what I would
do as a parent say, "You
can instill first memories
"into your kids."
But I think the technique,
I think the technique.
Well, I think you're
taking it a little too far
but--
This is sensational.
No what I'm saying is
that you've gotta use
this technique though.
When, and I think it sounds
like you did this, whether it
was intentional or not.
It was just two years too late.
When Lando started talking
about his memory you,
when they bring up something
like the rabbit we'll follow
the rabbit like literally
follow the rabbit
and ask them questions
about the rabbit that they.
Like let them lead it
and they'll kinda be,
they'll be recalling it
and also reconstructing it.
It solidifies
a rich memory that then when
they're 41 and 42 years old
and they're talking about the
good old days they'll have
less traumatic things to
talk about than we had.
Well and I think the video
component is a big one
because I don't, I think
that the first video of me
that's available is definitely
not before middle school.
I mean we didn't
Oh wow.
Nobody was taking any video of us.
Like my parents got a video
camera when I was already
in high school so we didn't
have a family video camera
and it was just like school projects.
The first video footage that I have
of me is my aunt Teesee.
She was big into these
camcorders and she would always
bring that to Christmas and
she would like, she'd set up
the tripod and she'd have
it in the corner of the room
and then she'd come
around and film everybody.
So every Christmas starting
like, yeah, when I was in like,
you know, when you started
getting those big shoulder mount
cameras, I don't know
what year that would be.
I would have footage of Christmas
at nana and papa's house
and I would take that camera
and not tell her and I would
film stuff at nana and papa's house.
I'd film like little videos
and I'd film this time travel
movie that involved flushing
the toilet and just filming
like zooming in on the
water and then like voicing
that over as like a time
travel portal and then I think
that was pretty much the only scene.
I remember that.
Okay, you think you can
get hold of this footage?
Mm, I bet she still has all
of it but it's just like
all of us opening presents.
You mean me filming the toilet?
Well that--
I think that was pretty much it.
Don't you think that you
should like digitize?
If she has footage of
you as a kid like I think
that you should get that digitized.
You should talk to her about this.
Yeah.
'Cause VHS tapes are not
gonna hold up forever.
They've already degraded
quite a bit probably.
I meant that's, I mean it
was definitely grade school.
It wasn't middle school.
It might've been.
Well, I don't know
if I've told you this but--
Sixth grade maybe.
'Cause you know I've got
that 360 degree camera right
and so one of the things I've
started doing on like our
vacations is in every city
that we went to when we were
in Scotland and England, you
know, I would take a number
of these pictures and I put
'em up, I think I talked about
it and I posted it.
But now I can put on my oculus
and I go to that website
while I've got my oculus
on and I can enter into
those photos and see, and
there's 360 video which
with the camera that I
got is not very high res
but the photos are great.
'Cause I can be like, "Oh
I remember when we were on
"that hike and we stopped
and we took that picture."
And there is Loch, there is
Shepherd and there is my nephews
and nieces and--
Because sometime in the
future it's just gonna be,
it's gonna be much easier
than putting on an oculus
to just explore that photo
and you will have some
of the earliest ones.
Well that's exactly what I'm
talking about and so I still
haven't, and I kind of regret
that I haven't done this yet,
but the good news is that my
kids' rooms haven't changed
substantially in the past couple
of years since we've moved
into this house but, you
know when you were like,
"What was it like in my room as a kid?"
Yeah.
So what I'm gonna do is go
in there and just like, you
know, stand in the middle
of the room, hold the thing
up and take a 360 photo,
or let them do it so
it's not dad holding it,
and then you've got
this photo that forever,
like for the rest of their
lives they can be like,
"What was it like in my room
when I was 11 years old?"
Oh, I can go there right now.
Oh and there's the book
that I was reading.
Oh yeah, I think that this--
There's my Garfield phone.
It's like that's something
that I would love to be able
to have, you know, I would
love to be able to do
that personally right.
But, you know--
There's a side benefit
of this too, you know,
for insurance purposes.
Like if your house burns down,
I know I'm a downer today,
when your house burns down
you can, if you've uploaded
those to the cloud then
you can just send 'em
to the insurance company and
say I want all of this back.
Well, that's actually, that
was actually my first idea
when I got this camera.
I was like I need to take
pictures of every room
in the house so that I can
actually show the insurance
company in case of a
fire but then I was like
oh but this also creates
like a literal memory palace
that my kids can go into.
That's right.
With these, with an oculus.
So what are we concluding here?
Your first memories, you
might have made 'em up.
But if you have influence
over a seven year old they're
at the perfect age to just
to cultivate out what Rhett
said an averred memory
garden of first memories.
That's the influence you can
over the next generation.
You can thank us for it.
And you know what when you're
talking to that seven year old
say, "Hey, you know what you
should listen to 'Ear Biscuits'
"that's where I learned this
from, you might be into it."
This is our target
audience, seven year olds.
And you know what I can
make a recommendation here
based on the camera that I have.
Okay, is this your official rec in effect.
Yeah this is my official rec.
Okay.
It's got 348 ratings on
Amazon, four stars, so I guess
it's been fine for me.
Like I said the--
It looks like a USB drive
with a lens on the end of it.
This is the--
Is it that small?
I don't know, is that Ricoh, how do you?
R-I-C-O-H, Ricoh.
Yeah, Ricoh.
Theta, Richo Theta SC 360
video and still camera.
Comes in four colors,
I have the white one.
Jessie just got this for me at some point.
How much is it?
It is, the white one's 180 bucks.
What's the cheapest color?
No, for a 360 camera?
That's cheap.
You said the white one.
The rest of 'em are 200.
Everything else is 200 but
the white one is cheaper.
Okay, 'cause it shows dirt.
And again like I said
at least the last time
that I, now that camera
that we used on the--
Going back to Boyds Creek
for the documentary?
Jack can you, do you remember what kind
of camera that was that 360
camera that we used when we
crossed the river?
'Cause that one was much more pricey.
That was more of a video camera first.
This feels more like flip phone.
Is it 4K though?
No, I mean, well it's,
let's see what it says here.
I don't know what the video resolution is.
Like I said this is basically
for pictures like the pictures
are adequate to like capture a memory.
If you just wanna, you can
actually then like upload them
to a website and go into it
and look at 'em or whatever.
It was just a GoPro.
Oh it was a GoPro.
It was the new 360 GoPro which
is, that thing for video is
awesome but you don't have
to go, 'cause that one's
more expensive.
I'm surprised you can't
just like get a phone that has
backward and forward facing
lenses, just hold that thing
up and there's a program
where you can just push a button.
Well there probably is, that probably is
a thing that exists.
Probably not quite as good as this though.
But that one's the future.
Yeah this one
is just like pretty seamless.
You know what if you don't
wanna take Rhett's rec
just wait a little bit and
your phone will probably
start doing it.
Well I just think in the
distant future everybody
is gonna have like some sort
of headware, even if it's
in your glasses and it's
gonna be like little antenna
goes up and now you've got the
360 and you're like I wanna
remember this moment, I wanna
remember everything about this
and I wanna be able to enter
into the physical space,
I want the sights and the
sounds of this situation
and you'll just be able to do that.
Yeah.
We should invent that.
In the meantime you can
just buy this.
I would call
it Google Glasses.
All right.
We'll partner with Google.
Okay, we can provide the glasses.
Yeah, we're just gonna provide the antenna
with a camera on the end of it.
Well actually we're not
gonna provide that at all
we're gonna provide the idea.
You just heard it, Google Glasses.
If you like the idea of us
having an antenna installed
on your Google Glasses--
Yeah I do like it.
Hit us up
and we'll tell you all about it.
It's an antenna with a camera on it.
Or if you wanna hit us up
in general #earbiscuits
let us know, join the
conversation, what's your
very first memory?
I think this is something
good, it's a good ice breaker
conversation for your
family, friends, loved ones,
or for conversations on
a plane, what have you.
We're here for ya.
And we'll be back next week.
Like I said we'll still be
talking about the "Lost Years"
in some capacity.
Yeah, thanks for listening.
Thanks for sharing this
episode with a friend who you
wanna remember or you
want them to remember
their first memory.
Tell 'em about our show.
We are in your debt.
Don't forget, remember to
tell 'em about our show.
We'll speak at ya next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on the circular
icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.